des écologistes des associations de
malades le dénoncé depuis longtemps les
risques en France liés à Tchernobyl ont
été sous-estimés confirmation dans un
rapport judiciaire qui vient d'être
remis à la juge d'instruction en charge
du dossier un rapport accablant les
mesures radioactif de l'époque ont été
occultés un document télévisé de 87
l'attestait déjà Patrick
Esther 20 ans après ternobyl un rapport
d'expert a donc été communiqué à la
justice française sur les effet
radiologique du passage du nuage
radioactif sur l'Europe en France le
sud-est et la Corse n'ont pas été
épargnés non le nuage ne s'est pas
arrêté à la frontière comme l'affirmai
les autorités en charge du dossier qui
n'avait pris aucune mesure de prévention
à
l'époque à ma droite à 200 m à peine
Strasbourg aucune consigne de sécurité
depuis l'accident de Tchernobyl à ma
gauche à 200 m à peine k en Allemagne là
les consignes de sécurité sont très
strictes
le service central de protection contre
les rayonnements ionisant le SCPRI
dirigé par le professeur pèlerin
minimisera alors les chiffres de la
contamination en réalisant des moyennes
par département qui gomment les pics les
plus importants de pollution des mesures
officielles relevées dans de nombreuses
installations de surveillance de
l'environnement par exemple celle de
l'EDF situé à proximité des centrales
nucléaires mais ces chiffres n'ont été
connus du public qu'en
1987 le ministre de la Santé de l'époque
qui avait la tutelle du SCPRI excusa ce
déficit
d'information le professeur pin et son
équipe sont des techniciens ils ont
travaillé comme des bêtes comme des bête
pendant un mois je crois que jamais
personne ne l'a assez dit car ils ont
sorti des milliers des milliers de
résultats avec c'est facile de donner la
liste de tous les gens qui ont été
touchés par ces résultats le problème
c'est que ça n'est
leur métier de faire de la communication
médiatique la justice doit maintenant
déterminer si ce déficit d'information
n'est pas directement responsable de
graves problèmes de santé pour des
enfants qui vivaient à l'époque dans ces
zones contaminées où aucune protection
n'avait été
prise